dog meat farmers in South Korea are
pushing back on a potential ban South
Korea wants to ban dog meat I don't like
dogs
I don't some people ask are you a dog
person are you a cat person I'm not I'm
a people person I like people but we
should not eat dogs the reason it's
wrong to eat dogs and the reason the
South Korean dog farmers are wrong and
the reason that the people trying to
reform this are right is because that's
not what dogs are for dogs are there to
be man's best friend they're not my best
friend but broadly they are a man's best
friend they were bred to be man's best
friend and that's why it's especially
cruel in a way that it's not cruel to
kill a needed cow killing a pig killing
a chicken the dogs are there and we're
bred even if you just want to look at a
purely historical evolutionary kind of
view of it to say nothing of a deeper
philosophical view they're there to be
our mate and our help and our buddies
and our Companions and it's wrong to eat
them